[موسيقى]
رغم زياده الانفاق العالمي ازمه تضخم تهدد
الشركات الدفاعيه وطلب غير مسبوق على
مدافع الهاوتزر بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا هذه
الملفات وغيرها نطرحها معكم في حلقه اليوم
اهلا بكم في عسكريتانيا
[موسيقى]
شركه جنرال اتومكس الامريكيه لانظمه
الطيران تكشف عن احدث مشروعاتها في مجال
الطائرات المسيره مسيره
هي مسيره وصفتها الشركه بانها ستشكل تطورا
جديدا بل ونوعيا في عالم المسيرات كما
انها مسيره متعدده المهام ومنخفضه التكلفه
ويمكنها التحليق لمده تصل حتى 60 ساعه هذه
المسيره ستكون لديها القدره على التحليق
في مجموعات لتقديم الدعم الجوي للقوات
افادت تقارير اعلاميه المانيه بسعي شركه
رايمنتال الالمانيه لانشاء مصنع للدبابات
في اوكرانيا
بالمناسبه هي الشركه المصنعه لدبابات
ليوبارد الالمانيه الشهيره والتي قررت
برلين مؤخرا منح عدد من هذه الدبابات الى
الشركه الالمانيه خصصت لمشروعها اكثر من
200 مليون دولار كما تستهدف انتاج 200
دبابه سنويا من طراز بانثر وبحسب الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه فسيتم تحديد موقع امن من
الهجمات الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا لانشاء هذا
المصنع لكنه لم يحدد هذا المكان
اعلنت القوات الجويه الامريكيه التعاقد مع
شركه بيرسي سيستمز لانشاء شبكه عمليات
اقليميه لاسلكيه لتغطيه 400 صومعه من
صوامع الصواريخ النوويه العابره للقارات
في جميع انحاء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الشبكه الجديده ستكون عباره عن شبكه رقميه
موحده وامنه تربط 75 مركزا للتشغيل واكثر
من الف مركبه تابعه لقوات الامن كما ستتيح
تبادل ومشاركه البيانات والاتصال المستمر
بين الافراد بالاضافه الى كونها ستوفر
الاساس الذي يمكن ان يبنى عليه النظام
قياده وتحكم مشترك ومتكامل للقياده
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
ليس خفيا انه منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
كانت هناك زياده ملحوظه في الانفاق
الدفاعي حول العالم خاصه لدى الدول
الاوروبيه التي تزايدت مخاوفها من
التهديدات الروسيه وفي نفس الوقت ايضا
رفعت التدريبات العسكريه الصينيه والكوريه
الشماليه من مستوى المخاوف ما دفع الدول
المجاوره لبكين هي الاخرى الى رفع
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لكن السؤال ما هي
تداعيات هذا الارتفاع العالمي في الانفاق
على التسلح على الشركات الدفاعيه خاصه في
ظل موجه من التضخم العالميه التي يعاني
منها العديد من الاقتصادات حول العالم
وكذلك ايضا على الامن العالميه حول هذا
الموضوع معنا من لندن المتخصصه في
الاقتصاد الدفاعي في المركز الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه السيده فينيلا اولا
السيده في اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتانيا على
مدى العام الماضي الكثير من الدول اعلنت
عن زياده ميزانيتها العسكريه لكن برايك هل
ست لتزم هذه الدول ام انه الامر لن يتعدى
مجرد خطابات سياسيه واعلاميه لا اكثر
شكرا على الاستضافه شاهدنا موجه من
الاعلانات من الدول في انحاء اوروبا بشكل
اساسي في اعقاب الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
فبراير الماضي تفاوتت فيما بينها من حيث
سرعتها وشدتها لكن الاتجاه العام كان
واضحا نحو رفع الانفاق على الدفاع
بالمقارنه مع اجمالي الناتج القومي واتت
هذه الاعلانات في اوروبا رغم التحديات
الاقتصاديه المتزايده فقد كان عام 2022 هو
العام الثامنه على التوالي لزياده الانفاق
الدفاعي في اوروبا والان تراجع المعدل
بسبب التضخم حاليا من الجيد ان نرى
استمرار هذا النمو في ظل الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا الذي حفز رفع الانفاق على
الدفاع لكنه كذلك عطل واضر الاقتصاد
الاوروبي بشكل كبير مما ادى الى التضارب
بين اولويات الانفاق العام بالنسبه لصناع
السياسات لذلك نتوقع استمرار ارتفاع الان
على الدفاع في اوروبا وهناك دول بدات
بالفعل في تطبيق هذه الزيادات في ميزانيه
2023 لكن اثر التضخم المستمر قد يعني ان
هذا الارتفاع لابد من تقنينه بعض الشيء
ناهيك عن اولويات الانفاق العام الاخرى
مثل الكلفه العاليه لخدمه الديون مع
ارتفاع معدلات الفائده
على مدى سنوات يعني تعهد الدول النيتو
بتخصيص اثنين بالمئه من الناتج المحلي
للانفاق العسكري لكن لسنوات ظلت هذه
التعهدات مجرد حبر على ورق هل ستلتزم هذه
الدول خلال المرحله المقبله وما هو انعكاس
هذا على تماسك الحلف
اعتقد انه منذ 2014 شاهدنا تغيرا في
مخصصات الميزانيه الدفاعيه بين دول النيتو
في عقاب ضم القرم وقمه النيتو في جارديف
ذلك العام كان حينها معدل المخصصات
الدفاعيه بين دول الحلف واحدا وثلاثه
من اجمالي الناتج المحلي ووصل الى سته في
المئه عام 2022 وهذا تقدم تجاه النسبه
المعلن عنها وان تم الوفاء بالالتزامات
فسيتم الوصول الى واحد وتسعه من عشره في
المئه بحلول الفين وثلاثين وهذا يعتمد على
عده عوامل من بينها تنفيذ الالتزامات
والتعهدات وكذلك على الاداء الاقتصادي
الذي يتسم بالغموض في الوضع الراهن شاهدنا
عددا من الدول تصل الى نسبه 2% المتعهد
بها ودولا اخرى اعلنت انها تهدف للوصول
الى هذه النسبه خلال بضعه مثل ايطاليا
التي تسعى لتحقيقها بحلول 2028 لكن
الزيادات المخصصات ستتواصل بشكل اكثر جدوى
مع تراجع التضخم وهو امر متوقع لكن علينا
ايضا ان ناخذ في الاعتبار القيود التي
يعاني منها الانفاق العام بمجمله اما خارج
اوروبا فالتضخم ليس قضيه اوروبيه فقط فقد
ارتفعت اسعار المعدلات عالميا حتى في عام
2021 راينا هذا الارتفاع بسبب الانتعاش
والطلب مع تراجع الجائحه واستعاده الدول
قدرتها على الانفاق سيده فانيلا يعني في
ظل العقوبات الغربيه الى اي مدى ستستطيع
روسيا تدبير ما تحتاجه من معدات عسكريه
وعلى الجانب الاخر هل هناك طريقه لمعرفه
حجم الانفاق العسكري الروسي في هذه
المرحله
في الواقع لقد كان اداء الاقتصاد الروسي
افضل بكثير مما كان متوقعا في 2022
فاجمالي ناتج القومي تقلص لكن بنسبه اثنين
واثنين من عشره فقط وفقا لصندوق النقد
الدولي لان التبعات الاقتصاديه للغزو
والعقوبات الناتجه عن ذلك قابله ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه والاحتياطيه لدى روسيا ما
دعم الاقتصاد الروسي وقد كان متوقعا ان
يشهد الاقتصاد الروسي تراجعا اكبر من هذا
فقد كان اكثر من عشره في المئه في وقت
سابق من عام 2022 عندما انهار الروبل امام
الدولار حتى في اكتوبر كانت توقعات صندوق
النقد الدولي ان يكون التقلص الاقتصادي
الروسي ثلاثه واربعه من عشره في المئه
وتحسن الارقام لتصل الى اثنين واثنين من
عشره حسب البيانات الاخيره هو دليل على ان
الاداء الاقتصادي في روسيا افضل بكثير مما
كان متوقعا اما البطاله والتضخم فقد شهد
استقرارا كما استعاد الروبي العافيته بفضل
اسواق الطاقه وكذلك جهود البنك المركزي من
خلال مضاعفه معدلات الفائده ووضع ضوابط
الراسماليه اما العقوبات فاثرها كان ضعيفا
على هذه المؤشرات الاقتصاديه على النقيض
من التوقعات وذلك لسببين رئيسيين اولهما
ان التكنوقرات الروس ادار هذه الازمه بشكل
جيد باستخدام التكتيك اتبعه منذ العقوبات
التي فرضت على روسيا في عقارب ضمها للقرم
اما سبب الثاني فهو ان العقوبات على
الطاقه من الغرب لم تفرض بشكل حاسم حتى
ديسمبر 2022 وبالتالي اثرها كان ضعيفا اما
الصعوبات التي واجهت روسيا فهي الادوات
التي لجا اليها الغرب فيما يتعلق بالتجاره
مثل القيود التي فرضت على استيراد
التكنولوجيا الحساسه وبالتالي عانت مؤسسه
التصنيع العسكري من مسائل هيكليه لفتره
طويله وعانت من التنافسيه الدوليه ومع
دخول هذه العقوبات اصبحت الصناعات
العسكريه الروسيه تعاني كثيرا وتعطلت
سلسله الامداد وهناك قيود ايضا على تصدير
الرقائق والمواصلات الدقيقه ما جعلت تصنيع
العسكري الروسي يعاني من شده النقص بمواد
الانتاج معطل انتاج الدبابات والاسلحه
التي تفوق سرعه الصوت الصناعات العسكريه
الروسيه تعاني نفس المشكلات التي تواجه
هذه الصناعه عالميا مثل نقص العماله
والمواد اللازمه والعقوبات الدوليه تزيد
الطين بالله من خلال عدم التمكن من الحصول
على الامدادات بشكل يمكنهم من استكمال
مراحل الانتاج العسكري
اكثر من مره عن انعكاس هذا التضخم لكن كيف
سينعكس هذا التضخم على اسعار الاسلحه
وكذلك على مدى قدره الشركات على الالتزام
بالعقود التي تم توقيعها بشكل مسبق وهل
نتوقع نتيجه مشكله نتيجه هذا الامر ام لا
شكرا نعم معدل التضخم يؤثر على جميع عناصر
الميزانيه العسكريه ليس فقط على المشتريات
بل ايضا على كلفه العماله والاجور وكلفه
التشغيل التي تشمل الوقود والصيانه وهذا
يشكل ضغطا على الميزانيه العسكريه وعندما
تكون التكلفه العسكريه عاليه فانها
بالضروره ستنعكس على ارتفاع تكاليف العقود
التي يجب ايضا ان تستوعبها ميزانيه الدفاع
هناك دول لديها اجراءات حمايه او تسعير
اجل في خطط المشتريات والميزانيه دول مثل
بريطانيا وامريكا ادخل التعديلات على
الميزانيه العسكريه بحيث تغطي مساله
التضخم وسمحوا بالتمويل لتغطيه العجز
وبالضروره فان اي تعطيل في سلاسل الامداد
يتسبب في رفع اسعار المواد الخام مما يزيد
من التضخم واي شيء يرفع اسعار جزئي هذه
الصناعه يؤدي الى ارتفاع التحديات لذلك
فان جميع الشركات تواجه صعوبات كلا حسب
موقعه لكن الشركات تستطيع ان تحافظ على
تنافساتها من خلال الكفاءه والاستثمارات
والمحافظه على تنفسيه قدراتها اما التطور
الاخر المهم الذي نراه الان فهو التوجه
للتعاون مع القطاع المدني في مجالات جديده
وهي طريقه لضمان بقاء هذه المؤسسات على
تنافسيتها
المتخصصه في الاقتصاد الدفاعي بالمركز
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا
على ما تفضلت به من توضيحات
[موسيقى]
سلاح الغواصات هو واحد من اهم الاسلحه لاي
قوات بحريه على مستوى العالم لكن السواحل
الضحله التي تحد بعض الدول دائما ما تشكل
عائقا امام قدره الغواصات على العمل فيها
تحديات دفعت شركه الايطاليه الابتكار
غواصه الثمن مائه
800 هي غواصه صغيره الحجم يصل طولها الى
51 مترا وارتفاعها يصل الى نحو عشره امتار
كما ستكون لدى هذه الغواصه القدره على
الوصول الى عمق يبلغ 250 مترا اس 800
ستكون لديها القدره ايضا على البقاء اسفل
المياه وبشكل متواصل دون الصعود الى السطح
لمده تصل الى سبعه ايام كما سيتم تزويدها
بمحرك شبه صامت هذا الامر سيمنحها القدره
على التخفي عن اجهزه الرادار او السونار
من المقرر ان يتم تزويد غواصه اس 800 ايضا
بخمسه تربيضات مضاده للسفن والغواصات كما
سيتم تجهيزها بمنظومات ملاحه واتصال
ومراقبه وكذلك انظمه حرب الكترونيه كل هذه
المميزات التي تتمتع بها الغواصه جعل
الكثير من الدول تبه اهتماما كبيرا بها من
بينها مثلا دول الخليج خاصه انها تتناسب
مع الطبيعه الجغرافيه للمياه التي تحيط
بهذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل باريس تضاعف انتاجها من مدفع
القيصر الفرنسي بعد ارتفاع الطلب العالمي
اهلا بكم من جديد شهد العام الماضي
ارتفاعا قياسيا في الطلب على مدافع خاصه
بعد الشهره الكبيره التي حققتها تلك
المدافع في احداث تغييرات ميدانيه جذريه
في الحرب الدائره حاليا بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مدفع قيصر الذي تنتجه شركه نيكسترا
الفرنسيه كان واحد من اهم مدافع الهوتر
كما وقعت الشركه المنتجه له على عده عقود
لبيعه لعدد من الدول حول العالم سواء داخل
او خارج اوروبا هذا طبعا بالاضافه الى
منتجات اخرى تقدمها شركه نيكستر الفرنسيه
من بينها مدافع وذخائر وعتاد عسكري اسلحه
جعلت واحده من اهم اللاعبين في سوق الدفاع
العالمي اليوم للحديث عن اهم منتجات
الشركه وبرامجها هنا في المنطقه معنا في
الاستوديو المدير الاقليمي لشركه نكسر
الفرنسيه السيد دومينيك اولا مستر ديمونيك
اهلا بك معنا في الاستوديو وشكرا على
وجودك معنا يعني يبدو ان مدفع القيصر الذي
تقدمونه في نيكستر متى يحظى باهتمام كبير
على مستوى العالم خاصه بعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا وما حققه من شهره كبيره لكن الى
اي مدى هناك اهتمام هنا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بمدفع القيصر وما الذي يميزه عن
غيره من مدافع الهاوتر
مساء الخير بدايه اود ان اشكرك على الدعوه
لاستضافه في برنامجكم اليوم كما تعلمون
فان نكستر هي شركه دفاعيه فرنسيه من
الاكبر في فرنسا واوروبا في مجال تصميمي
وتطوير وتصنيع معدات الدفاع البري فان
نظرنا الى ما يحدث في اوكرانيا نجد ان
هناك حاجه ماسه لحمايه الفرق العسكريه
وتوفير الذخيره لها وما يميز مدفع قيصر
سهوله الاستخدام واحتياجاته اللوجستيه
قليله كما انه سهل التحريك والنقل ولديه
قدره على اطلاق طلقات متعدده في الدقيقه
الواحده والتموضع في دقيقه ومغادره المكان
في دقيقه وهي طريقه جيده لتجنب المواجهات
مع العدو وهذا ما يجعل قيصر مدفعا حديثا
جدا وناجحا جدا للاستخدام في ساحات
المعارك لكن فيما يتعلق باهتمام دول
المنطقه بمدفع القيصر
مدافع قيصر موجوده في المنطقه وكما تعلمون
فان واحده من الدول الكبرى في المنطقه
اشترت بالفعل عددا لا باس به من مدافع
قيصر ووصلنا رد فعل ايجابي منهم عن
استخدامه وكفاءته كما ان القوات الفرنسيه
لديها اتفاقيات دفاعيه مع عدد من دول
المنطقه وهي تستخدم القيصر في تعاون
العسكري ونحن في نكستر نقدم خدمات الدعم
لعملائنا وبالنسبه للمنطقه فان جميع
عملائنا هنا يحاولون تلبيه احتياجاتهم
الجديده ونحن كشركه تجاريه نحاول ان نقدم
لهم افضل ما لدينا من تكنولوجيا لتلبيه
احتياجات هؤلاء العملاء
الرئيس الفرنسي منويل المكرو المحا مؤخرا
بامكانيه ارسال عدد من دبابات التي
تقدمونها في نيكستر الى الاوكرانيين ان
حدث هذا الامر هل تعتقد بانه الدبابات
لوكليرك مؤهله للتعامل مع ظروف المناخيه
وكذلك التضاريس الصعبه في اوكرانيا
من المهم الاشارات الى اننا هنا في هذه
المنطقه قد اعددناك بمواصفات خاصه لهذه
المنطقه وقد حصلت عليها الامارات لتصبح
بمواصفات خليجيه لتتناسب مع الصحراء ومن
المهم لاشارته هنا الى ان التصميم الاساسي
لدبابات مخصص لاواسط اوروبا وشرقها
وبالتالي فان التصميم الفرنسيه يتلائم مع
الطبيعه الاوروبيه لا شك في ذلك بالعوده
لسؤالك فنحن كشركه موجودون لدعم عملائنا
سواء فرنسا او الامارات او الاردن فالاردن
لديه بعض دبابات لوكلاخ ومهماتنا هي دعم
عملائنا قدر الامكان مصر التهديدات التي
تواجه اوروبا تختلف بشكل او باخر عن
التهديدات التي تواجهها دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط انتم في نكسر ما هي اهم المنظومات
التي تعتقدون انها مناسبه للتعامل
والتعاطي مع التهديدات التي تواجهها بعض
دول المنطقه وتتناسب كذلك مع الطبيعه
الجغرافيه لهذه الدول عايزين
منذ بدايتنا في نكستر ونحن ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار اسواق تصدير عندما نضع تصميماتنا
واهم مواصفات انظمه نكستر هي سرعتها
ودقتها وقدرتها على حمايه طواقمها فمن
المهم ان تعيد ابناء الوطن سالمين وهناك
فرص عديده في المنطقه والسوق لا يتوقف على
منتج او على لوكلاخ فقط بلدينا مجالات
عديده للتطوير مع عدد من دول المنطقه
وهناك امكانيات كبيره للتعاون
سبق
استراتيجيه بعض الدول الان في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تغيرت لم تعد تبحث فقط عن شراء
معدات عسكريه ولكن كذلك تبحث عن مشاركه
التكنولوجيا ومشاركه الافكار مع الشركات
والدولي الكبرى العامله في هذا المجال
ولديها خبره كبيره في هذا المجال بالفعل
هناك الكثير من الشركات الاوروبيه
والامريكيه الكبرى العامله بدات يعني
تتعاون في هذا المجال مع بعض دول المنطقه
انتم في نكسر الى اي مدى انتم مستعدون
للمشاركه مع دول المنطقه في هذا المجال
بالطبع من اجل نجاح في هذه الدول علينا
نقل بعض النشاطات ونقوم بنوعين من توطين
النشاط اولهما توطين الصناعه وسلاسل
الامداد قدر الامكان عندما يكون في ذلك
جدوى اقتصاديه وهنا في الامارات كان مستوى
الاستثمار الذي تم تنفيذه في السنوات
العشر الاخيره قادرا على جعل الامارات
شريكا كفئا نحن نرحب بشراكه مع الشركات
المحليه لتحضير للمستقبل وهذه فرص
مستقبليه نجهز لها كما نتعاون بشكل وثيق
مع المجلس الاقتصادي لتحقيق النجاح فنحن
نلتزم بتنفيذ تلك المشروعات التي اتفقنا
عليها مسبقا هذا بالنسبه للامارات اما
بالنسبه للسعوديه فمن المؤكد ان التعاون
مع السعوديه اساسي
لمستقبلنا في المنطقه سواء في مجال
الدبابات او الاسلحه او الذخيره فهويتنا
كشركه تشمل تعاون مع هؤلاء الشركاء
المدير الاقليمي لشركه نيكسترا الفرنسيه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
مقاتله ثقيله متعدده المهام بدات تطويرها
مع اشتعال الحرب العالميه الثانيه كما تم
تزويدها باسلحه متنوعه لمهام الهجوم
البريه والبحريه المقاتله البريطانيه
بريستول او الموت الهامس كما اطلق عليها
اليابانيون شركه بريستون للطيران المصنعه
لهذه المقاتله قامت بتزويدها بمحركين كما
تم تزويدها باول رادار جوي حينها لتتحول
الى مقاتله ليليه كما اجريت عليها تعديلات
عده وانتجت منها نسخ متعدده دخلت هذه
المقاتله الخدمه في عام 1940 ومع اشتداد
المعارك بين بريطانيا والمانيا وتعرض
المملكه المتحده لغارات جويه مكثفه من
الالمان نجحت هذه المقاتله بشكل كبير في
حمايه الاجواء البريطانيه ليلا من
القاذفات والمقاتلات الالمانيه
تم تسليح المقاتله بريستور بوفايتر باربعه
مدافع رشاشه ثقيله من عيار 20 ملم في
المقدمه واربعه مدافع رشاشه متوسطه من
عيار 7.7 مليمتر على الجناحين هذا
بالاضافه لمدفع رشاش من عيار 7.7 مليمتر
يطلق يدويا من قمره المراقبه في منتصف
الطائره لاحقا تم تزويد بعض الطرازات من
هذه المقاتله بثمانيه صواريخ جو ارض من
عيار 75 مليمتر للاستخدام في الاسناد
الجوي القريب كما تم تصنيع نسخ اخرى
للمهام البحريه زودت هذه النسخ بتربيد
واحد او قنبلتين تزن كل قنبله مائتين
وخمسين كيلو جرام
النجاح الكبير لمقاتله الموت الهامس دفع
بعض دول الحلفاء لشرائها واستخدامها على
جبهات عده خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كما تمت صناعه اكثر من
5900 نسخه منها حتى خروجها من الخدمه في
العام 1960
[موسيقى]
حلقه عسكري تاليا لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]